in today's warning rounds a recent study
found some common drugs could increase
the risk of dementia or dementia-like
symptoms the study in JAMA International
Medicine discovered a nearly 50%
increase in odds of dementia in people
55 and older who took anti colon jarric
medications that type of drug is used to
treat a wide range of conditions
including depression symptoms of
Parkinson's disease of bladder control
and insomnia we reached out to the
makers of antidepressant Paxil for
comment but have not heard back an
estimated one in four older adults take
anti colon jerok drugs some
antihistamines like benadryl are also
anti colon jarek's but were not
associated with dementia in this study
CBS News medical contributor dr. Tara
Narula joins us now so Tara this can be
confusing for people because this word
anti colon Jarek is the first time
they've ever heard of it's very hard to
understand what that is but this is a
very broad class of medications and
really what we're talking about are
drugs that block a neurotransmitter or a
chemical messenger called
acetylcholine right this is one of the
first neurotransmitter discovered very
widespread in the body throughout the
central and peripheral nervous system
and it has a lot of functions it dilates
blood vessels it regulates muscle
contractions bodily secretions heart
rate and in the brain it has effects on
attention concentration and memory and
like you said a lot of Americans use
these drugs whether prescription or
over-the-counter ranging from things
like antihistamines or anti allergy
medicines sleep aids bladder control
medications Parkinson's drugs COPD meds
I mean the list goes on and on so how
significantly can anticholinergics
increase the risk of dementia well this
is very interesting so we knew about
some of the short-term risks associated
so these drugs can cause things in the
short-term like confusion delirium
memory changes but the idea was that if
you come off of them it may be
reversible in the mid-2000s more and
more research started coming out saying
well actually there might be long term
effects where it may be increasing your
risk of dementia and as you mentioned
there was a study just last month that
looked over to at over 200,000
individuals in Britain who took a strong
anti
cholinergic drug for three years and in
fact found a 49% increased risk of
dementia nine percent forty nine but
it's important to point out as with a
lot of studies this was not a cause and
effect studies right so most of these
studies have just shown an association
it's an observational type study in
addition a lot of researchers have said
look some of these drugs that were
giving the antidepressants and the sleep
aids we're giving to people who may have
had dementia all along because some of
these things like depression and sleep
loss are signs early signs of dementia
so it may not be the drug themselves
that's causing this so there's a lot of
these combinations of drugs seem to be
the root cause of the problem my
question is like with so many doctors
making so many prescriptions really it
seems like the buck stops with your
pharmacist
well the pharmacist and the doctor and
the patient when everybody needs to be
informed about this and the fact is that
elderly are more susceptible to these
types of problems and there are a lot of
reasons why we say that you know we know
that the blood-brain barrier that
permeability or the ability for
medications to cross increases as we get
older the amount of acetylcholine that
neurotransmitter decreases in our brain
as we get older so you can imagine if
you're now giving a drug that blocks it
you're gonna have a stronger effect the
body may not process the acetylcholine
as well and a lot of the elderly may be
on multiple medications so it's a
cumulative effect we know if you if you
stop taking these drugs that the effects
reverse themselves well this is just a
growing body of research right as I said
this is Association so what researchers
have said is what we really need is a
randomized control trial which is the
gold standard type where we take people
who are on these medications and then D
prescribed we take them off and we see
what happens to their risk of dementia
but really important is just to speak to
your doctor right and every visit you
should be going over all your
medications and saying do I need to be
on this is it really working for me and
what are the potential risks and
benefits are there alternative agents
that might be good for me and don't
assume if it's over-the-counter that
it's safe it may not be right benadryl
some of these other medications you can
buy over-the-counter Tylenol PM Advil PM
if you're a patient talk to your doctor
but if you're a care taker you might
want to review the medicine that the
person in your charge is taking one of
the cases described in the literature
was really remarkable woman went from
severe dementia changed her medications
suddenly she's back to a
functioning right and so patients with
dementia should really not be on these
medications at all so yes important if
you're a caretaker as well
all right Tara thank you very much